RV Airbnb Part 2.
My husband so graciously dug all the trenching
for water and power.
Now I just need to lay the lines
while we still have the mini excavator.
My husband cleared the spot,
and then I asked him to go back over a few times to
make it nice and flat.
The ground, please.
Then we picked up a pallet
of dormant Bermuda grass from a local grass farm.
Here I'm having the kids trying to help me,
and they were super excited to help.
Um, help lasted about five minutes before they got bored,
but we did get all the grass put down.
Um, this will look nice and green once so it comes down.
Can't wait for spring.
I see Zinya's banana plants and elephant ears.
I just can't wait for it.
Here are some of the listing images,
and I am gonna replace that mattress
because it's super fun
waiting for a new one from Amazon. Um,
but here she is,
and I cannot wait to have our first guest on the farm.